- On se croirait à la veille
d'une guerre à grandlllllllle.
"Gloire à l'Ukraine," a déclaré
le président Volodymyr Zelensky
en paradant son artillerie
dans l'est du pays.
Plus tôt, il s'est même
rendu dans les tranchées,
pour encourager ses troupes
et les préparer au pire.
"Avec vous, je suis confiant
que nous allons tous
les battre."
Une référence aux dizaines
de mil s s s s soldats russes
qui se déploient depuis
des semaines aux portes de
l'Ukraine, et qui, cette fois,
selon le renseignement
aiaiaiaiain, seraient prêts
à l'envahir à tout moment.
L'OTAN et ses alliés préparent
donc la réplique, si elle
s'avère nécessaire,ttttt
le président américain qui
aujourd'hui s'en est fait
l'émissaire.
Joe Biden et Vladimir Poutine
ont discuté pendant deux heures
par visioconférence.
- Good to see you again.
- On n q q q q que
les politesses. Après quoi,
il aurait prévenu le chef
du Kremlin qu'une invasion
lui coûèèèèèès chère,
comme jamais auparavant.
Le Kremlin n'a pas commentél'ls
Vladimir Poutine maintient
depuis des semaines que
toute tentative d'expansion
de l'OTAN en Ukraine sera
considérée comme une menace
existentielle pour son pays.
Pour cet analyste, il est
clair que Vladimir Poutine
cherche encore à négociers s s n
sécuritaire et veut le respect
des accords de Minsk, qui
prévoient un statut spécial
potototototototoires
par les séparatistes prorusses
dans l'est de l'Ukraine.
C'est aussi ce que pense
la majorité des gens que
nous avons entendus dans
la ville frontaliè
Mariupol, en Ukraine.
"Il n'y aura pas d'attaque,
adadadadadadadadimirovna, car
la Russie n'en a pas besoin
et l'Ukraine encore moins."
"Mais on a peur
jeune femme, nous sommes
pacifiques et des victimes
collatérales d'un jeu
politique."
Un jeu ouououououououout.
Car c'est la deuxième fois
cette année que la Russie
utilise la menace d'une guerre
pour négocier avec l'Occident,
tetetetetetetete.
Autrement dit, l'OTAN
a intérêt à se préparer
pour toute éventualité,
etlllllllllllllllle fait.
Et la Maison-Blanche confirme
que, parmi les sanctions
envisagées, suspendre
le grand projet de pipelinem m t
alimenter le gaz naturel russe
vers l'Europe, cette fois,
fait partie des options.
Ici Tamara Alteresco,
Radio-Canada, Mosco